you guys ready for some I'm ready I am
ready i season finding does that count
towards the edge okay
I roll [ __ ]
good alright I roll in for ya good Roy
thank you thank you thank you
hey do you want to go I roll another one
I roll all right already [ __ ]
cheating little [ __ ]
so I guess it goes Ethan Bob me mark so
you actually know how to play cat's head
right Bob Lee yep Bob Lee put her spine
it was one time it was a lot while ago
should explain what Ethan needs to do
then because I goddamnit house okay you
place a house in the road and then we go
around the circle and then I'll place
two in a row and then we go bruh verse
order and then the game starts this is
not me placing my thing I'm trying to
spot in the numbers mean whenever
somebody rolls that number yeah that
thing is [ __ ] amazing
[Laughter]
[Music]
Thank You Amy Amy got me a drink
thanks Amy it's my mother [ __ ] call
me king of the mountains
really that's I'll just say where's the
[ __ ] thing because you could just
totally [ __ ] do it that's right no
wait I thought the one that I put on was
stone brick brick brick brick brick and
stone I'm gonna take this one saying
take the brick
yeah the brick kind of screwed us all
over last game fine don't worry about me
I'm good I like this room that we're in
right it's a classy
I think mark stands wait you don't get
to say [ __ ] I'm going last year you've
got plenty of red territory everywhere
I'm not gonna get any I guess I'm gonna
go here I'm building in the ocean I give
up I've got house place both your roads
both your settlement got it hang on hang
on I'm thinking I'm gonna go slower
Stone Lord and then I'm gonna do this
move oh I was gonna go there you [ __ ]
oh you unbelievable what up monster dick
what did I do
I was gonna take that little two-spot
thinking know what else would want it
what you've got or brick in shape and
that's it yes and guys yes yes do you
[ __ ] go there's plenty of other two
spots where you talking about this one
by the wheat the brick weight would do
great in medieval times probably also
get executable wait this is there no God
bricky sheep he left listen nice moment
is weight still going yes cheese get
skipped no my turn didn't good oh wait
how [ __ ] up what wait where are you
going that way building again why did
you get to build again yeah we go Bob go
I'm [ __ ] tell you take your time I
don't like any of it I don't like any of
it you guys need to relax
no no hang on no oh no stop no no get
rid of that hanger get rid of that it's
hang on
it's come on disguise the penis a quick
a quick side game of disguise the penis
okay disguise draw something extended
clip
why is it we don't have home or dick on
our bridge I can put it anywhere I want
right as long as at least two spaces
away from another settle yeah not there
so the only definitely not there let's
go here with his life don't I don't help
him you think he's gonna go here I did
go there originally oh wait we gotta
take we gotta take the cards from now
you draw your entire thing is
from the second one you place right well
[ __ ] what oh god I got 11 brick hang on
so have some trouble there more hang on
I gotta I'm trying to put my cards back
no only you can see them I can I can
come flippy-flippy but I can't actually
see him good good I can't see I've got
no brick and really awful sheep cool
really awful oh yeah yeah wait y-you
can't complain because I get someone
else's voice came out you know what you
you you know wait it's right wait is
right right on this one we we are wrong
wait is right okay I hate that one that
one creeps me out
hey no you don't like that one I don't
my neck and I don't like it just please
stop wait if you set up that interface
that's sitting in that closet literally
miles I have a stream deck I think I've
got two mixing boards another one it's
on the way why do you have any other
mixing board on the way I love you but
you're one of the laziest people I know
do I roll yeah click and drag to select
them both yeah hey the wheat nice nice
guys wish I had a weed
that's a dope eye so I take anything I'd
take anything yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I just take one right yeah I
realized now I should have placed this
one first in that one second so that I
could have gotten three stone I don't
know why no no no I did also realize
that I did this in a poor thing for
myself
and I'm a dominates alright alright so
you do anything over there eat Sam nope
do you want to give you boy lady at
brick I'm going oh wait you rush I
should have written I know cuz you've
placed your second summer roll good roll
Ethan pay attention 1 0 the ones that
are green on the board are the ones that
are currently you take oh here next to
oh if you're next to it turquoise chip
you take one if you like drag and select
in your hand I think you can maybe
switch multiple of them yeah you can
multi-select you have to do it it not in
the one at the bottom but the one in the
actual cards I accidentally I know I did
we just said click and drag dude are
these the cards are these the cards what
three sheep a wood in a wheat I believe
right I think that's right yeah that
seems right probably we the eight gave
you a sheep and you started off with two
sheep and a would write what could roll
that's another good for me oh boy we we
mean we made so I'm gonna play a wheat
I'll play sheep oh I see what you don't
play nor I see
I see what you're doing here Bumi's but
do me alright well you done I'm done
all right make way for big dick Mick me
[Music]
alright
finished my turn yeah go for it if you
can alright if I can suede yes cells
I've got nothing
hey listen I don't have any words of
encouragement I'm sorry it's okay but
let's go try to be nice but it's it's
seven that is the unlucky number yeah
well seven look alright if you get eight
well yeah if you roll seven if you roll
some if you have eight cards in your
hand get to get rid of half of them I
thought you saying seven cards you're
saying rolling yeah um you're done right
anything yeah you don't want to have
more than seven cards in your hand
except a sevens roll on good one doing
bad
what are you doing bad oh I don't have
many new things wait do you want to get
rid of the sheep for wheat no I really
you wanna you want to wait for a sheet
yeah I'll do it
I think that's good for ya mark can't
get wheat yeah I do this yeah thank you
no I'm over here orange thank you thank
you thank you I'm done okay anybody in
trouble no I see yeah I see some people
that should be in trouble I see
everybody but me everybody but me don't
target me look at this juicy one right
here look how that all over three of us
will be affected by that we know my road
goes right over there I have to look at
that dump when I walk up and down my
Road terrible for everyone
hey now come on damn it okay I think you
should leave the desert where it is you
have to move it unfortunate hmm but it
could move into where nobody is weighed
[Laughter]
Bob and Mark and no brick for anybody
that's not why do you want to hurt
everyone if you if you want brick Wade
you should feel from you or still from
work for brick or I could just trade you
some brick and that way you wouldn't
risk not getting brick would you trade
me a brick I don't have Rick to trade
right now but I will trade you brick
because I can get brick I don't steal
from me because then you just steal it
back okay yeah then I'll trade with you
yeah I'll trade with you wait I already
said about anything he wants I'll trade
with you wait wait I said I'd do it and
I said I'm here but you promised gonna
steal from me right okay you promise and
sound like you promised you rely on you
promise you promise promise I promised I
will I'll block this [ __ ] III hear
uh-huh okay not even like the best thing
sure and I'll just hear you know what Oh
little seven I'm gonna roll the dice
here odd is Ethan evens Bob what's the
air fair fair fair to move your brick to
the far right now won't take that card
said I'm not indicating to you which one
is my break
I was not I was honorable with mark I
was gonna be honorable I still don't I
have no faith when we played board games
together that over if I were to need
help that sounds fair
sounds fair sounds fair if anything is
you right fair is fair yep what number
we what effect we're using for that
really long reverb delay thing and by
another card but you not setting up your
mixer when you have it makes me we're
playing without why are you doing that
yeah that's good Wade you got an 8 I'm
just gonna drag a grain into your
inventory okay okay all right it's fun
having almost everyone playing games
together I'm here you right are you
actually setting up the mixer right now
no it's staying in the box so I can look
at it to think about setting it up later
all right does anybody think about
something does anybody want to get rid
of some wheat for what I don't have any
wood unfortunately do you have any stone
I can't get rid of stone so unfortunate
what do you offer Rick
I've got brick yeah you want brick I'll
give you a
perfect go ahead yeah ok I'm going to
I'm going to make you have to have two
roads oh except for me come on so you
have two in a row somewhere
[Laughter]
give me one of them Stoney boy I mean
bricky boys all right Bob I've got a
special discount I need to get rid of
some cards so okay I've got uh do you
have any would you don't do I don't but
okay well what what do you have I've got
two sheep one brick III got to get rid
of two cards so so what do you want I
guess then what do we what do you I mean
I'll always take more wheat because I
can't get it so yeah what do you two
sheep or a sheep and a brick two sheep
would be better for me all right cool
can do and so I have this two for one
sheep port so I'm gonna turn these
shapes into one wood and play yeah play
a stone and feel the road nice nice Road
all right very proud of you that's not
the place and then yeah turn these bad
boys in and I think that's all I got I'm
out of move some good anybody have brick
for trade what do you got I have wheat
and or I will take another or or brick
yeah all right all right so I just
bought a settlement which is going here
on this little port nice damn that's
nice
that's really nice thank you all right
my turn I guess cool and big role big
role I get some of that okay so what I
need to do is I'm gonna play three stone
one two three and then two wheat I'm
building a city right not there I'm
building city right method of building I
see you know me babies you yeah it's two
resources from every number on it what
all right so I did that and I've got
that city and I'm done
five green sex okay well well well well
well does anybody have any brick I do
not know what are you willing to trade
for it I guess
do you have sheeps I do I have many oh
you have many I set a problem do you
have too many well have two sheeps can I
have two brick el they have the one now
you only have the one I'll give you two
sheeps hope snap do sheep's for brick
that's nice resource some reason I can't
get my own shapes right now it's got a
brick now so I think he's going to be
longest road I'm going to build a
settlement all right that's not what I'm
placing it
[Music]
[Laughter]
at the wood port so that's a two-for-one
deal on anything right oh yeah yeah I
figured that was not the mist I did not
take I don't take anything he says for
granite
okay is it my turn oh joy of joys it's
two of those things I get to you do
right
okay he gets to mark or away do you guys
both have a lot of like or going on over
there you got new extras not final
unfortunately wait what are you offering
I well I pretty much I have a wheat and
sheep to offer for two or yeah I can't
do that sorry yeah no maybe
all right let's let's do this I'll do
this Wow I'm just I'm thinking I can't
get wheat right so like I got it true
that's true I got to think ahead for the
long run
right fares there worked out boom so I
am done all right Wade don't let me down
baby you got it
Oh sick powers in your hand again so
does anybody want to just give me an
order for free to avoid this wrath I
don't have any all right the Sheep
still misshape guys I'm happy to
announce that Indian food is having free
delivery today I'm gonna get some tea I
feel like you guys are being too casual
about the devastation that is about to
be unleashed by well I think Wade knows
I think Wade knows how to punish people
he doesn't he definitely doesn't have
what I need
yeah I don't have what you need you
watch the king of the mountains why
didn't you just just do we're gonna
block two people sub one there's a one
right here where there's just Ethan
there's nothing Ethan doesn't have what
I need and there's one right here where
you just blocked marking it's fine for
you what you need back no I don't want
it back it's okay mark I'm developing a
strong wheat production we're in this
together we she ate this you and me I
didn't want to roll a seven or in this
together we're in this equation just
mark to seven our to work on post mates
yes if no one's trade me an orchard okay
you know the powerwall
huh all right I really this really came
through for me guys this really came
through
so I'm play or look at all this or I got
Wade look at all this or I'm playing all
this you needed for sitiing up I'm yeah
yeah
yeah where I'm sitting up again to City
baby
to City mmm I am in it to win it
my voice feels good - yeah well I'm done
so you guys move on with your life
that's quick that was good thank you my
turn amazingly most turns should take
about that long wait damn you damn you
wait
damn you wait why did you have to punish
me why my offer to not go there so it
would give me an or I offer
nobody had or I had [ __ ] 3 no I got
three I had one and I didn't want to
give up my one because I wouldn't
believe the myths or no not me already
has any or I would my spot anybody have
any brick huh no nobody has sponsor all
shitty and I was also punished okay well
I think I'm done then alright yeah you
are you are done you're done yeah you
right there you go marking eatin yeah
[Music]
the or man one of my ores that be that
behind my turn maybe he's gonna head Wow
waits for whatever in the world it is
[ __ ] cheating I'll Justin I'm sorry
but I wanna leave Bob mark alone for
turns on leaving a lot thank you Bank
thank you we're not taking any Goodwood
all right well guess bad wood I took the
bad wood he's does the nine that bad
it's one worse than the nine all right
you're right you're right you're right
you're right just try to be somewhat
nice right took that one wait why did
you take it you [ __ ] ass here's a
couple wheat there's a weed there's we
just stop cheating in rolling sevens huh
Oh mr. desperate for or suddenly as a
bunch of or somehow how'd you get that a
funny old how'd you get that buddy huh
so much tuned all have trusted you for a
long time I know you really did yeah you
put that there yeah you would you would
put that
yeah really not depressing actually all
right mark you done do it good I'm gonna
do this good watch this guy's you we're
on the nine until last role I just moved
it you're welcome you're welcome for
stealing those oars from me
thanks you know what I'm gonna do no you
know what I'm gonna do you know what I'm
a oh yeah why are the stealing from you
oh yeah no stealing from you yeah you
too Bob you got robbed all right you
know I'm gonna do he was still in that
nine or frost using my port for two or
two one I'm getting who would all right
well done and that's my turn
thank you thank you for listening okay
[Laughter]
okay fine do you have any weight I
totally got you covered bro no wait I'm
gonna hear him out marketing to would
write you're like an idea where anybody
got any brick no
no one's gotten any break I'm not on
break anywhere even Wade took brick from
us our mark and I would both have for
some brick on the for brick for brick
yes you are
wait Ethan I'll do I'll do stone for
wood I'll do stone for wood one stone
for wood yeah I'll do that you do it mmm
yeah I was gonna all right well first
you know don't be sorry you offered me
first an offer and I was like and then
like two minutes later you were like oh
maybe maybe he's got another would you
want to ask again maybe he's got another
one my turn yeah yeah I guess oh you're
not gonna ask okay I get it
I'm assuming it was done because more
cards than I thought I didn't think he
had enough to do anything so I assumed
he was done oh that's right I'm just
gonna do this cuz this is my only joy
yeah it was a good move that really
helped me out yeah it did it did was six
I get two of those I I set out way he
just done sorry I had my own voice in my
head for you wouldn't have that problem
listen
hello six again god damn it don't see
don't be mad I wrote a six and I've got
weeks I'm gonna put three oars and get
another I feel like you're getting more
ore than I am some
five oh my god you are oh you gots
alright yeah
oh my gosh you're putting a city there I
sure AM buddy boy man I feel like I feel
like Wade's in a really good position
right now
Wow yeah well now I can't do anything
else for a long time because I can only
build so many cities before I've got to
have a freakin woman alright well here
we go you Don Wade I'm going to trade in
these 3 weeks for a brick you Wow and
you would then I'm going to play this
would you really force someone takes it
from me and I'm just gonna put a road
somewhere I don't think you would do
that you want to go I mean you could
connect your two cities hmm good I'm
gonna start working over here toward
break okay see guys can't you just be
happy from we can no no you already put
it down Wade what's the deal come on
it's fine I've no other car all right
here we go I'll do stuff that's what
that is
all right I I am gonna turn in two of my
or for brick damn alright so we're going
brick and wood and I'm just gonna build
a road how do you even have wood what
huh no you just got one last time let me
see where I don't have really jammed you
in around pretty much every corner yeah
pretty much
you're pretty much hold like any eights
have way cuz no one's got she know
I could go I guess how [ __ ] I God why
did you all pile up around me like this
or you you you do you looked at that Bob
you looked at it and you're like because
I thought to myself man being in the
middle of those oars would be terrible
because everyone would build around you
lie to me you right don't lie I never
lie
you wouldn't lie so I can't lie so don't
try to lie I'll go here yeah all right
I'm done okay my turn
here's a question yeah I think I already
know the answer do you have to buy what
did I roll you need to move the robber I
get to move the ran who has been moving
that robber everywhere and just given us
all a big that [ __ ] you guys where's
the best position it's gotta be no no
right which red get away from me wait no
more of that for you all right you need
to steal one of my two cards oh I wonder
what they are think about it think of
hard don't take the one that I wanted to
keep which one no no okay well now
here's a question okay my question was
yeah do you have to have a settlement at
like the corner to get to the thingy or
can you just have a road leading up to
it does anybody have any brick stats
Dylan oh wait do you want what are you
trying to get to do you want the brick
port or do you want like a three for one
no I want the brick port okay you don't
have any brick I was gonna say you I
mean you're on two bricks but there's
just I would not advise it because
you're not gonna get much prick to use
that trade very often
however I don't see a good three for one
near you so I mean I guess that is a
port you could get wait I would I trade
in any two materials for one brick right
no you tried to trick anyone material oh
right now your port is trade to wood for
any one material oh yeah okay well that
changes yeah like you could go here
that's fine like it you could get
another thing on the brick but that's
not to get brick that's to get rid of
brick okay well in that case nobody has
any brick though you know that they're
willing to trade gets what I would I
have wood what do you need would you
like some Queen not in your world go
away I both question your language City
is that
[Laughter]
Ethan still doing stuff yes what's he
buying he's doing something Oh brick you
just give three no I get four okay where
did they when to put this room trust
them I want to put it here when do you
get a development card a victory point a
developing card wait when do you get
development cards you buy them with
sheep wheat and or one sheep one weed
one or you know Bob did you just borrow
one come one no I just got an or because
our older 9:03 points they can be
Knights they could be properly card I
think they can be road builders is that
a thing in this diversion
yeah I think roads you guys are do
monopolies reef steal people's resources
do you get an I treat Robert or you can
get victory points I think those are the
options I'm gonna play this even though
I don't really want to do the other part
of it move the Robert Steele one okay
yeah I have to do the robber now I'm
gonna do the least amount of harm whoa
maybe which is it's gotta be this one I
guess and I get to steal a card from
Ethan hey Mark king of the ORS man who
could not get any weeds you wanna wait
for an or old buddy
it's my one weakness yeah I got that
locked in down there you sure do
I wonder where I'm playing that city are
you doing it man thinking thinking
processing plastic that's a good move
good move man real probably done nine
[Music]
five seconds man
wait are you done yeah wait before
you're done Wow
schemes schemes I don't like it you know
what I'm gonna risk it cuz what are the
odds I'm gonna play a seven right all
right it's fine you're done yeah so long
as this isn't a seven I'm gonna be very
happy nice brick
I am going to trade for of my or in for
two brick well that's all right and the
night's not so good I'm playing you can
do four or four Tariq he's got a port
got a tooth oh okay so this is to brick
and Noel okay it's all lumpy it's to
brick and to wood I'm gonna pull [ __ ]
two roads going this way nice oh [ __ ]
and that will be my nice turn thanks man
alright seven baby I would really like
to draw some cards that people could
stop rolling sevens please yeah the only
places where I'm only screwing over one
person I guess I could move it back to
the desert couldn't I yeah hey hey wait
look at this oh look look at what a
greedy Meriton I am oh yeah I can steal
from anybody
No
right uh it's fine I like being a hero
karma right but I'm not in this game but
yeah go for it does anybody have any
wheat know what your thing is rolled I'm
not dry I normally have many wheats but
I have none I oddly have one week but I
don't think I want to get rid of it okay
how badly do you need it though what are
you willing I mean I'll give you one of
either wood or sheep never in your
entire existence would I trade with you
[Laughter]
okay well I'm gonna make a road shut up
interested no you don't you mean what do
you want do you want this three for one
is that what you're working toward or
you just try to get more resource ah see
that's what I'm trying to think of cuz
you could build a settlement right here
or you could build a road here and get
on the five so you have another number
and you could work down to the three
four one five then get down on the 405
take Sepulveda do you have you do have
the two weeks if you build there and get
that wheat port you can do a two for one
week yeah that's what I'm thinking so
I'm gonna put it there thank you I'm
done it was a decent life turn yeah it
took two minutes in 38 seconds I am
[Laughter]
alright Bob okay I guess I'm gonna roll
bricks who has that wood who got wood
got wood what are you worried for I just
got some wood yeah I have stone Ethan
I'll give you a stone for a wood okay oh
really is that all about that [ __ ]
I just I don't like it when Bob is like
oh really you'll accept my I got
two-for-one Shippo Shippo port so that's
two roads modified with you with you
with you feeling you okay I'm just gonna
join those bad boys up and just oh yeah
and that is the only thing I did lots of
stuff I'm done eleven fun
nobody and sweet that's the first time
I've gotten sheepies in a long time to
be an [ __ ] and not be nice and play a
night card doesn't sound good he's been
so sweet and nice I just feel like I
should wreck his life think carefully
let's talk about this does anybody want
to make a deal before I move this Robert
why do you always say that what do you
want what do you want any brick brick
but does that get me immunity yeah if he
does if you trade it for a doing an or
or a sheep you're doing even Stephens
trades and immunity you're giving away
the farm win I don't need those wait I'm
sorry but you do have
you suck so much this is what you get
for participating in [ __ ] if you give
him the brine no he won't he's an
honorable man I'll do what were you
offering cheaper or I'll do the Sheep
then turn around and screw me over I've
never don't Ethan needs to learn you
don't put this in the desert you'd be a
dick do you have any you don't want me
to take someone take this one I should
have not done the deal because overall
thank you thank you
the whole turn oh sweet not a generous
man no am I not fair god hey I gave you
guys a chance for immunity Marc took the
deal I took it's not race for immunity
if I literally don't have the thing here
that's like saying that you if I floated
what I say I've left you alone the last
two times I've moved just because I
don't have anything
Wade you done I think I'll stop there I
think that's my evil turn all right
that's a winner
I'm guessing nobody wants a sheep one
sheep I mean I got got to I guess what
are you searching for my sheep full I'm
looking for a wood I was gonna offer you
a wheat for a sheep but that's basically
my only offer sorry one weep one wheat
one sheep yeah I do that and I could do
that
here always I gave you so quickly that
was those the other sheep
I had another sheet okay I'm done with
my turn and I'm gonna go to the bathroom
so just you guys don't screw me over
while I'm gone
all right Bob you want to cheat while
the sewer go kind of dude I feel like I
feel like we could easily swap Ethan's
good number over here on yeah thing that
helps both of us yeah or we could get
rid of his nine cuz that doesn't quit we
could put that nine would you guys share
anything
really sure are you scheming against me
no no we're scheming against mark yeah
okay because with Mark we feel like we
could get away with it we know you're
way too astute is it my turn
can we trade marks five for my four so I
can get some goddamn bricks no yeah yeah
he'll probably notice the nine though
it's been rolled a lot recently here he
went to pee it's your turn it's your
turn mark I'll just give him his
resource if you need me would I
definitely debris have I been screwed no
okay wait do you have a whole lot of
materials maybe you should give me one I
think he just means give you one and
yeah I'm just taking it would you like
to do a trade in which here you know
nothing sure man
I stole it from them and I felt like a
Dixie just traded for it well does
anybody have any wood no no do you have
a brick Wade I F brick for you I'll do
it right now
you can't do it right now don't give
your hiding
I don't think Ethan has brick to offer I
don't have brick to offer I'm trying to
get brick I am the brick boy all right
Bob would you like a sheep for a brick
no that's not what I mean or for a brick
nope got that Wade would you like a
sheep for would know I'd rather trade my
wood for Bob's prick
why is my chat saying you guys cheated
the six but we didn't it's still a six
take the six five this three here or
something you guys are so funny
sometimes I look at you guys and I laugh
and I laugh and I laugh I just keep
laughing because you guys makes life so
fun all right I think my life is over
[Laughter]
because I just got Indian food delivered
to my door are you still down for that
situation one of these bad boys one of
those bad boys no I didn't roll do I
have to roll first doesn't matter we can
trade whenever but you can I mean I
think you have to roll before you're
allowed to like get rid of cards that's
sick nasty for bricks right
can I trade you one more brick for one
more wood are you into that yeah oh you
were your way into that wait can I get
promise that you won't roll a seven can
I just get that promise if you let me
play cards before I roll no I can't but
just it just fix it by not doing that
that's all you got and a settlement dude
Wow right
longest road do your thing how do you
need to win a 1000 seven well you're
wrong you can be seven it's not it's not
seven okay well it's not I tried not and
yeah that's pretty much it I got double
I roll double so I get to go again right
just don't roll put that pressure on me
that's what I've got a few cards here so
let's go brick wood right right
sheep there we go and I'm gonna build a
little house see house right here now
what the [ __ ] am I gonna do god damn it
all I guess I'm going to [ __ ] give away
one of your cards if you know not one of
those and I'm going to do one of these
not one of those okay hmm
fascinating I think marks gonna roll a
seven I just feel it in my life I don't
want that energy out in the universe
he's just all I gotta say about that I
mean I'm not trying to like jinx you or
whatever it's at it but it sounds like
it just smells my grundle can smell it I
guess is how I'm going to decide to
explain now I know it's okay rogues I
got nothing to do with these relapses
you could treat something of me why are
you jumping on my dick over here
anything you complete your circle that
would have been cool don't
why'd you make the circle well because I
liked it at first now I'm listen are you
done you done yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
for one wood I'm playing one of these
one is one of these I'm building one of
these right here I and then gone -
anybody want brick I've got a shitload
I've gotta think brick what do you want
for it come on brick that's a question I
suppose you're right okay I've got four
brick do you want to brick huh for what
one of each okay fair is fair there is
indeed fair and with that I'm also going
to play don't it has begun my
development development all right I'm
good all that wheat you got I can't wait
to see how this ends dude you you you
know me I know you and we know each
other and you know how this is gonna end
you done bro even lengths turn I'm I'm
gonna win for sure yeah I believe it's
my turn
all right okay okay no no I do you know
why not I'd rather have the she's lying
I feel like there's a living his best
life I'm storming in it's a five again
okay well I would ask if anybody know
that's a thing I've heard of a sudden
these two sheep are you training in two
sheep well I was gonna do two sheep
where's to two or two sheep yes I was
gonna do two wheat and get two cards but
do I want to do wait I'm confused is
what you just did I put in two sheep and
sheep into the piles did your post mates
get there a second time you're being
salty about a hungry one here I'm ready
for some Dindin
um hungee God all right so what's doing
with that extra wheat you got there
wait what are you doing I might sniff it
probably smells pretty good right
instead of sniffing yeah maybe what are
you offering for it I've got brick do
you have another sheep I do
I'll trade one for a sheep are you gonna
get another development card with this
what I do with my sheep I don't care I
don't care to get another development
card I'll give you a and I'm gonna play
this night oh wait that was one of the
new ones you just got I'll play this
night God okay I will play one of these
three nights oh please I just being a
stickler for the rules because you're
about to [ __ ] win yes he's gonna have
largest army which is one victory point
but then he is also going to have be
able to get another two cities probably
with all the [ __ ] ease about steel we
have I don't really care where I put
this I'm just gonna you guys care which
one I block with this I care pretty
strongly I don't care about all of my
property
pretty much I'm not willing to sacrifice
a thing in my horrible a lot of treaties
but we didn't have one this time let me
steal it's mainly just so that way you
get under set under eight cards in case
you're PI just I do this no it's just
not it's not nice it's not fair do you
care which one I take I mean yeah you
wanna give it break or something yeah
I'll take a break instead yeah I thought
you were gonna draw a break from you
toss it away bricks I how many what we
can look get anymore look I have the
only strategy I have
I have only one strategy ballsacks
look it's not I'm in a death spiral I'm
obviously not gonna win at this point I
bought a car with the sheep's alright so
your turn great thank you
mmm
tasty rule I ever turned did you steal
my life no screwing mark over it's
actually wonderful
I was nice I gave him back his or listen
I try to be nice about things all right
my will not try to be nice it's not
gonna do any good but I'm still
whichever card you want I still don't
like you
I missed you brick I missed you brick
okay all right shits about to move all
right just get get suck in your lungs
and blow out your ass it's it's going
down suck and blow I okay I wow I can't
do anything right do something I just
have to think about how I'm gonna most
gracefully lose at this point that's
what I have done I just have so many
options of my masterful moves that I'm
about to lay down no one complained when
everyone else is there just because I'm
thinking about no I'm not Sean I'm gonna
do it like this
I'm gonna do this like this you all are
gonna suck my ass and I am gonna blow it
back out of yours
so first moon of the epic moves that
I've got getting a development card
development cards one at a time I'm
[Laughter]
about to lay down the law in the most
masterful way you've ever done seen that
anyone has ever done right really oh
you'll wait long for one would we've got
this and two bricks that I took back for
two roads cuz baby I'm coming for you
I'm gum
this way baby we're going through the
desert I'm next turn I'm gonna get you
oh wait it's not over yet
we're gonna I'm just laying the
groundwork um playing some pipe to clean
out the trash heap please God just
playing yo I'll play it alright um I
think I'm done alright that wasn't that
cool
[Laughter]
why did you roll twice oh wait I clicked
the wrong thing
okay the 12-bit enroll the nine-year-old
no I
[Music]
maybe I'll be a settler that's because
they're a rule um when you can play
Knights can you play nights before you
roll no I think well actually I don't
know I think you have to roll first no
matter what because the risk of getting
a 7 hat does anyone I think the night is
different but I want to check the rule
on that we don't want to have any wheat
no no no I need wheat for a city I don't
have any weed good thing I'm blocking
off that epic wheat yeah way the
development card comes after the roll
first first year ole then you can do
everything else okay and do a risky move
not a cool move all right yeah I guess
my turn is done
well that sucks me okay that was bad
just someone to my table it's gonna use
some of those that's okay that's fine I
don't need those it's half my hand right
yeah I'll move it away from everyone if
someone has a wheat they'll give me no
one has been as we I got stoned guys
remember stone you want stone back
[Laughter]
if you get a development card you get a
victory point right
only if it's actually a 3.0 only if it
says victory point it is if I can't have
so I'm gonna just monopolize brick a
little bit I guess
good I don't think you want you can take
it okay I'm pretty much the only thing I
want at this point is sweets I'm just
gonna stone Lord of Stone Mountain
like so many stone you're gonna move the
robber and play a knight oh it's not
over really so he's got monopoly
somewhere in there so he's just gonna
give us all the dick before he wins take
all the stuff Travis could win like a
brick in a wood or something I don't
have a wood I have five some bricks do
you want to trade a brick for an or take
away this brick
[Music]
is everyone do brick four or before
trying no no one was super Bob then okay
now who's taking [ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
hand me how you unbelievable piece of
garbage you can give me stuff if you
want good talk good talk
that's my time good turn here we go good
turn
mark yes how how many do you need
anything can I give you anything to help
you win I can't win you're the only one
set up the winner me for winning cuz
you've been targeting me the entire game
every time you were like I'm just gonna
put it here in this place where no one's
gonna get you wait I'm coming to get you
here's this okay here we go it's about
to go down
I've got what you saw last time it is
going down no that's a road it is going
down this time
1 2 3 4 right 4 stone BAM put those in
there I get to wheat back oh but wait
they're not staying there long cuz
here's here's these then there's this
one and this one city going in here
let's lap down here and bottom bing bada
boom
but wait that's it mark says he's not in
a position to win player this guy I mean
[Laughter]
go for it eat and do it but we got three
impressive break and whoa
[Laughter]
so yeah I also want to make a deal hmm
what do you want I guess is the first
question are you gonna steal it from me
yes I am why is this card separated from
the others well reason what's happening
you have to move the round you're just
gonna take a card from wait can I keep
it on wait yeah that thing they said you
could put it on our brick and block both
of us our my or you tick yeah I did you
have like an infinite supply of or ten
rolls so far
[Laughter]
[Music]
would you like to just give me the wood
no I want nothing you have to love the
optimism were for a wheat I would do
that I'll give you an ore for a wheat
you give me I think my turn is finished
lot of my problems I'm doing so
breathing like that to intimidate you
good good good does anyone have any
sheep they don't want I do not have any
sheep I got wood if someone were to rob
me at this point they'd get a wheat for
your wood you at this point yeah I'll
take I'm gonna make some moves you guys
ready first moves them
and then what's that huh what's that huh
hmm that's pretty good that's pretty
good
what are you doing I'm building a road
[ __ ] see this road you know I
was gonna win this turn like stealing
longest road just for the record were
you like stuck out I don't believe you I
don't believe he was because he'd I
would I don't need would you have that
oh he's got the car never in my life
[ __ ] okay well I guess I'm done all
right so here would have been my win
with road-building but I misplaced I
should have put this road here I should
have goddamn I told you to go for the
circle I told you you were right you
were right right all right all right
so I'm at victory points cuz I got two
four and then the two settlements makes
six largest army makes eight here's nine
and I guess let's build a city then
since I can't take longest road and all
wouldn't that way did way to win I
figured it was gonna end that turn
anyway so that's why I said you know
what you're lame you're lame way your
boys leg you lame no you lame I was
gonna trade three or four a would then
use law Rhoda's all that I get three
roads when you're laying it's a goddamn
Road you're lame
you're lazy you you couldn't have taken
longest road from if you hadn't built
that road I could have had it still been
six and sixty four but no I I could have
traded three or four okay you're lame
got him if I would [ __ ] up this one
goddamn [ __ ] drew I drew two cards
and I got two pieces of garbage
I had nothing the entire time what is
your forgot about that you get two
resources from the bank that's pretty
good not late game when all I needed was
[ __ ] victory points that's good
that's true
go to build some cities are better early
game not what's all if only if all I got
for resources with the one sheep I had I
couldn't
I think that's true that 5 6 roll at the
end was really nice for the sheep and
the wheat in the bore their I guess I
could have built a city now I don't have
anywhere I could have built a city yeah
you you got one but I think overall I
did pretty dope
yeah 84 points yeah Wow new year 24
victory points that's pretty good
[Music]